tune in for that now the chancellor
Jeremy Hunt has been speaking in the
last few minutes about the sale of the
UK arm of the collapsed U.S lender
Silicon Valley Bank let's take a listen
well there was never a systemic risk to
our financial stability in the UK the
bank of England Governor made that clear
from the outset but a number of our most
promising and important technology and
life science companies had their money
with Silicon Valley Bank in their UK
Branch so we've been working over the
weekend I've been in constant contact
with the governor of the bank of England
the Prudential regulatory Authority the
prime minister to work up a solution we
do not have that solution a sale has
been agreed to HSBC which is Europe's
biggest bank one of the most credit
worthy institutions in the world and
what that means is that all those really
important companies that had deposits
with Silicon Valley Bank UK can access
their deposits can access normal banking
services as of this morning it's a very
important outcome no taxpayers money has
been used and I think as a result of a
lot of hard work but I also I think it
shows that the UK has great resilience
in its Financial system that we're able
to step in with one of our biggest UK
banks in a situation like this and
protect a very important sector
it has been a weekend of frenzied
activity we know that why was it so
important to get this done quickly
well when you have very young companies
very promising companies they're also
fragile they need to pay their staff and
they were worried that as of eight
o'clock this morning they might
literally not be able to access their
bank account some of them only had bank
accounts with Silicon Valley Bank UK and
so for that reason we were faced with a
situation where we could have seen some
of our most important companies our most
strategic companies wiped out and that
would have been extremely dangerous we
have built over the last decade the
third largest tech economy in the world
after only China and the United States
so it's very important us as a country
that this sector thrives and that's why
the Prime Minister I the bank of England
were all rolling our sleeves up over the
weekend to make sure we had a solution
okay but this whole crisis emerged from
something completely unexpected the
collapse of a U.S bank because of
unforeseen circumstances unforeseen
weaknesses in the financial system How
concerned are you that there might be
other similar situations growing up
inside the financial system
well we always have to watch everything
that's happening everywhere in the world
when it comes to financial stability but
what I would say is the Bank of England
is very clear the UK banking system is
extremely secure it's well capitalized
and I think we demonstrated that
resilience by what was happening over
the weekend and the fact that we were
able to come up with a solution so
quickly and final question why did you
push for a sale there are there were
other options on the table well we were
Keen to make sure there was a solution
that protected our Tech sector protected
these companies
we were neutral as to what that solution
was except for the fact obviously we did
not want taxpayers money to be used but
we were looking at all options and we
needed to be sure that if the sale
didn't happen we had other Solutions
ready that's why it was important to do
a huge amount of work on a variety of
solutions over the weekend